after my Saturday afternoon matinee with
my custom to scuttle home for tea time
and Star Trek okay you embarrass me I
have an appointment your name please sir
God P I see a D it's nice to see you up
and around again first officer Patrick I
just need to talk to you because I heard
that you initially were a little bit
hesitant about reprising the role of
John Luke Picard
I would describe what you've just said
has the biggest understatement I wasn't
a little hesitant
there have been interest over the years
at different times which I had always
very firmly turned down not because I
didn't think what we did was good on the
contrary I'm very proud of next
generation but I felt that after 178
episodes and four feature films that we
had said everything that needed to be
said about our world and to go back to
it would be perhaps something that might
undermine the work that we'd already
done but when I got into a room with
Alex Kurtzman and Akiva Goldsman and
Michael Chabon and Kirsten buyer and
they began talking about their feelings
about the new series and I sensed right
away that we were going into a different
world and that's important because we
are living in a different world the
world that we were in 19 years ago when
we wrapped the last movie the fourth
movie is not today and I think our show
is is illustrating that very tastefully
please sir someone's after me I have to
help her
you really want to go back out into the
cold
more than ever he said what has it been
like for you voyages into this new world
this iconic franchise it's yeah there
were a lot of words to describe a very
very nerve-wracking I mean just for me
stepping into this world that I knew
very little about upsetting little about
but in in the course of the past what
does it feel almost seven eight months
of of working on the show and now also
getting to meet fans getting to do Comic
Cons it it broadens the view of it so
much when you suddenly realize just how
important this this show is this
universe is and how much it means to
people and I feel like that's the
biggest takeaway is how we are touching
people and how we are representing our
world just as Patrick said how we are
changing with the times and how how
important that is well and of course
you're working alongside a legend have
you been able to glean any advice he's
alright no I mean Patrick isn't one to
talk down to anyone or or or make it
seem like he knows more than you he is
always just a fellow actor that's what
he always presents to everyone and and
and he is the perfect captain as we have
you know he's Picard is known to be the
the greatest captain ever and and it's
true for the man himself he is the best
leader of this show and guiding all of
us because we we're all a lot of us are
entering into Star Trek for the first
time and we have the best possible guide
and mentor you know it works both ways
yes because I am I am when we're
shooting the season I'm working everyday
with actors most of them who are more
than half my age and I am learning to
because in any art time changes how
people work you see it in paintings
and architecture and that's what is
happening now and the great blessing for
me is being exposed to these fantastic
actors and watch how they work and how I
interact and can interact with them has
been a lesson for me well you know sir
patrick ET has been with you on your
star trek journey from the very
beginning so let's boldly go to the set
when you were shooting the Star Trek
next generation promo in our very first
interview with you in 1987 and I'm
playing Captain jean-luc Picard
yes come in 60s I was familiar with it
when I was an actor first working with
the Royal Shakespeare Company in
stratford-on-avon Warwickshire England
resonate was my custom to scuttle home
for tea time in Star Trek before an
evening of King Lear or Hamlet or Henry
the fourth part one okay take me back to
that first year what does it feel like
seeing that video again it's a little
embarrassing and I talk too much and I
still do thank you for not trying to
talk me out of all of this happily man
no better
[Music]
you